you've been using 10 years why'd you
start
come on come on
i'm wood i work in treatment be a fresh
start for us
[Music]
then go
don't worry you're not in trouble it's
not easy to ask for help
that's why it is the greatest privilege
in my life
to help you change yours we are a family
i'm gonna let you in on a little secret
since 2008 every health care provider
needs to cover substance abuse treatment
this is what we in the treatment
industry call gold rush
so how much are they paying you
tina bonafide first timer he's not
making a dollar
hey man how can i get in utah
welcome to the team
[Music]
hello this is the addiction services
center
what is this is the american injury
they go to treatment you get the kick
back and then they get a piece
that's it it's capitalism baby
[Music]
a lot of what i do is not pretty these
people
they're going to get high regardless
sobriety is a long
slow process utah some are lucky enough
to make it
most aren't hey utah
you're gonna give me my money
well i have never seen anyone look so
miserable counting money
there's not a lot of people that can
make something of themselves
[Music]
how do you feel yeah we have a winner
we're partners man we trust you
that's great i'm gonna place you on a
breeze this made nine grand in two
minutes
[Music]
god is great
you